it is interesting to take the point of
view of all kinds of life forms on earth
of viruses of bacteria they have a very
different view
and you know it's like the instagram
channel um nature is metal right the
ethic under which uh nature operates
doesn't often
coincide correlate with human
morals
it seems cold and
um machine like in the selection process
that it performs
i am an analyst i'm a scholar an
intellectual and i feel i should
carefully distinguish predicting what's
likely to happen
and then evaluating or judging what i
think would be better to happen
and it's a little dangerous to mix those
up too closely because then we can
have wishful thinking and so i try
typically to just analyze what seems
likely to happen regardless of whether i
like it or whether we do anything about
it and then once you see a rough picture
of what's likely to happen if we do
nothing then we can ask well what might
we prefer and ask where could the levers
be to move it at least a little toward
what we might prefer
it's kind of so you know useful but
often doing that just analysis of what's
likely to happen if we do nothing
offends many people
they find that you know dehumanizing or
cold or metal as you say
to just say well this is what's likely
to happen and you know it's not your
favorite sorry but
um maybe we can do something but maybe
we can't do that much
this is very interesting
that the the cold analysis
whether it's geopolitics whether it's
medicine
whether it's economics
sometimes misses some
very specific aspect of
human condition
like for example
when you look at a doctor
and the act of a doctor helping a single
patient
if you do the analysis of that doctor's
time
and cost of the medicine or the surgery
or the transportation of the patient
this is the paul farmer question
you know is it worth spending 10 20 30
000 on this one patient
when you look at all the people that are
suffering in the world that money could
be spent so much better and yet
there's something about human nature
that wants to help the person in front
of you and that is actually the right
thing to do
despite the analysis
and sometimes when you do the analysis
you um there's something about the human
mind that allows you to not take that
leap that
irrational leap
uh to act in this way that the analysis
explains it away well it's like uh
for example
uh the u.s government
you know the d.o.t department of
transportation puts a
value of i think like 9 million dollars
on a human life
and the moment you put that number on a
human life you can start thinking well
okay i can start making decisions about
this or that and with a sort of
cold economic perspective and then you
might lose
you might deviate from a deeper truth
of what it means to be human somehow you
have to dance because uh then if you put
too much weight on the anecdotal
evidence on these kinds of human
emotions then you're going to lose
you can also
probably more likely deviate from truth
but there's something about that cold
analysis like i've been listening to a
lot of people coldly analyze
wars
warren yemen warren syria
israel-palestine
war in ukraine
and there's something lost when you do a
cold analysis of why something happened
when you talk about energy
uh talking about sort of conflict
competition over resources when you
talk about geopolitics sort of models of
geopolitics and why a certain war
happened you lose something about the
suffering that happens
i don't know it's an interesting thing
because you're both you're exceptionally
good at
uh models
in all domains
literally um but also there's a humanity
to you
uh so it's an interesting dance i don't
know if you can comment on that dance
sure
it's definitely true as you say
that for many people
if you are accurate in your judgment of
say for a medical patient right what's
the chance that this treatment might
help
and what's the cost
and compare those to each other and you
might say
this looks like a lot of cost for a
small medical gain
and
at that point
knowing that fact that might take the
wing
you know the air out of your sails
you might
not be willing to do the thing that
maybe you feel is right anyway which is
still to pay for it
um
and then somebody knowing that might
want to keep that news from you not tell
you about the low chance of success or
the high cost in order to save you this
tension this this awkward moment where
you might
fail to do what they and you think is
right but i think the higher calling the
the the higher standard to hold you to
which many people can be held to is to
say
i will look at things accurately i will
know the truth and then i will also
do the right thing with it
i will be at peace with my judgment
about what the right thing is in terms
of the truth i don't need to be lied to
in order to figure out what the right
thing to do is and i think if you do
think you need to be lied to in order to
figure out what the right thing to do is
you're at a great disadvantage because
then people will be lying to you will be
lying to yourself and you won't be as
effective yes and achieving whatever
good you are trying to achieve but
getting the data getting the facts is
step one
that's the final step absolutely so it's
uh i would say
having a good model getting the good
data
is step one and it's a burden
because you can't just use that data
to uh
arrive at sort of the easy convenient
thing you have to really deeply think
about what is the right thing
you can't use the so the the dark aspect
of data
uh of models is you can
use it to excuse away actions
that are unethical you can use data to
basically excuse away anything but not
looking at data lets you expose yourself
to pretend and think that you are doing
good when you're not
exactly
uh but it is a burden it doesn't excuse
you from
still being human and deeply thinking
about what is right
that very kind of gray area that very
subjective area
that's part of the human condition
you